round three of the London chess classic  the deciding stop on the grand chest  tour with all the games drawn from the  first two rounds the world's elite  players came into the day hungry for a  win  world champion Magnus Carlsen sacrificed  upon against his old nemesis Vishy Anand  but some slick defensive moves from the  Indian superstar forced the tour leader  to scramble for a draw I don't really  know where things went wrong for me  world number 2 Levon Aronian found  himself struggling to prove real  compensation against the fence of genius  Sergey Karjakin  but a well-timed raw offering mutual  time pressure allowed the year's most  successful player to escape without a  loss the fact that they're playing clean  draw first it's a bit self-selects in  this hole you should generally have two  offers the tension is rising as the  players give it their all in search of  that elusive victory round for action  starts right now